[intense electronic music]
- Good morning, Matt!
I'm gonna show you
how I get through my day...
without falling asleep
on the toilet.
- John, how is waking up
at 6:00 a.m.
to play basketball
gonna help me?
God.
- Endorphins.
Intense physical activity
floods your brain
with endorphins.
You don't need sleep
when you can trick your body
into thinking
that you're constantly
in a life-threatening situation.
- John.
♪ ♪
With endorphins,
you can power your way
through any obstacle.
Oh!
Foul.
With adrenaline in your veins,
nothing can get in your way!
[grunts]
Oh, Jesus.
That's a goal-tend.
Okay, nothing can get in my way.
[grunting] Gotcha!
Oh, gotcha, big man.
[grunting]
[exclaims]
Let me get it!
You're a filthy, scumbag,
dirty-ass...
- I get it.
- Trifling player.
And you're always gonna be
a dirty player.
Let's go!
With endorphins...
everything is possible!
Oh!
What?
How?
[woman singing indistinctly]
- Ow!
- So there was an incident
on the basketball court
this morning
involving two
Hampton DeVille employees.
You and me.
And I think
what we've learned
is that people--
me and you--
make mistakes.
And nobody is really
at fault here.
Okay?
- Yeah, it's okay.
- Good.
Good meeting...
and great game.